how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel to cosmic
wander where we talk about Marvel and
everything relating to the MCU
and today we have a ton of Marvel news
specifically concerning phase for both
shows and movies
it looks like movie theaters are
beginning to open back up so for those
of you who have been waiting to go to
the movie theater I have some good news
for you in this video
it looks like Disney and Marvel Studios
has given the green light for production
on all of the shows that have been
postponed so that's excellent news as
well and then we have a lot of news
about phase 4 including Hawkeye one
division Falcon and the Winter Soldier
the Loki series and Black Widow as well
so I'll go over at all and I'll break
down everything that you need to know in
this video if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all things relating to the MCU and so
you can enter my weekly giveaway for a
chance to win a Hulk Funko pop from
Avengers end game all you have to do is
subscribe like the video and leave a
comment down below so to start it off
real quick let's talk about theaters
opening back up it's been reported by
discussing film that a National
Association of theatre owner
representatives has confirmed they
expect 90% of the global theatrical
market to be open by July 17th this will
be right in time for Christopher Nolan's
Tennant that is coming out now for those
of you who are waiting to go get inside
of a theater again this is really good
news however of course there will most
likely be some social distancing
guidelines that come with the theaters
reopening and although Tennant still has
its original release date it's widely
expected that not many new movies are
going to come out in July or August but
this is good news because Black Widow is
supposed to come out in November and if
movie theaters start opening up in July
that means that movie theaters will be
open for four months before Black Widow
comes out in November meaning that the
release date probably isn't moving and
the Black Widow November release date is
very very solid so it looks like we're
really not going to have to deal with
any release dates moving back any longer
and this is also backed up by the fact
that Marvel Studios and Disney are
opening back up again in fact they're
giving the green light and beginning
production again on all of the shows and
movies that they were currently working
on before they had to shut down due to
the pandemic they have begun to work on
Matar again in New Zealand and it looks
like the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
Wan division and the Low Ki series are
going to begin production again in July
now again this is really good news
because Falcon in the Winter Soldier and
one division were supposed to come out
this year and they most likely are still
going to Falcon and the Winter Soldier
only has about three weeks left of
filming and one division is in
post-production already now there is
some news of reshoots and more filming
that I'll talk about in just a bit but
starting production again in July is
plenty of time for both of the series to
finish everything that they need for a
2020 release date on Disney plus and
this all seems to be in full motion as
on Tuesday the Los Angeles County task
force presented guidelines for immediate
reopening of film and TV production and
theme parks so everything in Hollywood
specifically at Marvel Studios and
Disney seems to be getting back to
almost completely normal again
obviously there are guidelines that
they'll have to follow to be safe but it
looks like these shows and our movies
are going to be coming out right now
when they're stated to come out black
widow in November of 2020 and then
Falcon and the Winter Soldier and one
division this year as well so let's
start off with some news about the one
division series although we've heard
that filming has been completed for the
first season of the wan division series
it looks like they're going to start
refilling again in July this could be to
complete scenes that they may not have
shot before or it could be for reshoots
but we do know that it is confirmed that
this is what they're doing Paul Bettany
who of course plays a vision was
planning on attending Tampa Bay Comic
Con but unfortunately he will not be
attending anymore he had to cancel and
according to his representative it's
because he had to go back and do some
more filming for Wanda vision in July
now we've pretty much thought that
filming had already been completed for
the one division series but the
interesting part is that they're going
to resume filming in LA and not Atlanta
where they begin filming now they've
been in post-production for a while now
so this most likely means they just need
to reshoot a few scenes to get right and
again this is really good news because
it means that it's not getting pushed
back right now it does seem like we're
getting it this year now before we dive
into the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
Loki and Black Widow news we have some
Hawkeye
and Young Avengers news we haven't
really had too much happening in the
Hawkeye world but today we have a
production grid for it including when
it's supposedly going to begin filming
it says that the shoot date for the
Hawkeye series is going to be on
September 28th of 2020 filming in
Atlanta Georgia where Marvel Studios
films most of their shows and movies and
this shoot date is also seemingly
confirmed by Charles Murphy who put out
a tweet yesterday stating that he has
seen this shoot date for the Hawkeye
series all the way back and March so
this shoot date is supposedly very
legitimate but what's really interesting
is the plot summary that this gives the
project summary reads Clint Barton aka
Hawkeye passes the torch to Kate Bishop
Bishop takes up the Hawkeye mantle after
Barton she is also a member of the group
known as the Young Avengers
so we already knew that Hawkeye was
going to pass on the mantle to Kate
Bishop but we didn't know exactly how
involved Kate Bishop was going to be
with the young Avengers or what impact
the Hawkeye series would have on The
Young Avengers however it looks like the
Hawkeye series might actually be the
show to start the formation of The Young
Avengers with Kate Bishop possibly being
the leader Kate Bishop is going to get
actual training from Hawkeye he's going
to teach her how to be him essentially
so all of the training that he's gotten
is going to actually be transferred to
her and this is going to be very
different than most of the other young
avengers wicken and speed will probably
have some training with their powers
if iron lad comes in he may have a
little bit of training with his powers
and the same thing goes for Miss Marvel
and then if Cassie Lang becomes stature
she may have little to almost no
training except for watching her dad
from what we heard Scott Lang doesn't
want his daughter to go off and join the
Young Avengers so although a lot of the
Young Avengers might have a little bit
of training Kate Bishop is going to be
the only one who has been trained by an
actual Avenger intentionally she'll be
the only one actually trained to be an
actual Avenger which will make her a
perfect candidate to be the leader of
the young Avenger team now there will
obviously be some adult in charge of
this perhaps spider-man or Captain
Marvel but with the exception of one of
those two it looks like Kate Bishop is
going to be the leader of the young of
dangers and now we have news about the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier series
it's been reported that they're going to
resume filming in July just like Wanda
vision now we recently heard some pretty
interesting news about the series
Charles Murphy from Murphy's multiverse
comm has reported that if they're going
to do a second season of the Falcon in
the Winter Soldier they'll have to
retitle the series now that implies that
Bucky or Sam are going to lose their
title of the Falcon or Winter Soldier
which implies that one of them most
likely Sam is going to go on to become
the true Captain America in the first
season now this is expected even though
most of us thought Sam was just going to
go into the series already being Captain
America since Steve Rogers gave them the
shield at the end of Avengers endgame
but of course we know that US agent John
Walker is going to be Captain America at
first but based off of this report that
season two would have to be retitled it
looks like Sam will go on to become
Captain America which is why season two
will have to be titled something like
Captain America and the Winter Soldier
so for those of you who were worried
that we'd never see Sam as Captain
America it looks like we don't have to
worry any longer and along with one
division and Falcon and the Winter
Soldier the Loki series looks like it's
going to pick back up in July as well
now Loki still seems to be on track
however we have a very interesting
report by Atlanta filming they reported
the other day that if Falcon and the
Winter Soldier airs in August it will
have curiously lengthened episodes but
Loki they might be able to split up
which would be weird since it's a
multiple season story already
this is implying that the Loki series is
going to be a very very big deal more
than one season has already been
confirmed and now the support makes it
look like that the shows might actually
be stretched out into two part episodes
now they do go on to say that nobody
really knows and they'll know more next
week but it sounds like they've done
quite a bit of filming already don't
have a lot to cut out and have more
filming to do as well and again this
implies that this story is going to have
a big impact on the MCU and that's most
likely due to the fact that Kang is most
likely going to make his debut in the
Loki series Kang will most likely go on
to become the MCS next major villain and
most likely the Avenger
five villain as well and since his story
is going to be tied into the Loki series
it would make sense that they can't
exactly cut a lot of scenes out of the
show so that's really exciting but more
details on that next week and to top it
all off black widow news it's looking
like we're going to be seeing a lot more
of a young natasha romanoff in the Black
Widow movie than we thought the Marvel
fandom has discovered an actress by the
name of Anechka her Instagram does not
have that many followers however she is
followed by Marvel Studios now a while
back we did hear rumors that Marvel
Studios was looking for actresses to
play a young Natasha this was for
flashbacks of her childhood well there's
quite a bit of evidence that this girl
is going to be playing a young Natasha
if you go to her Instagram page her very
first photo of her is of her in Budapest
and she has red hair she was most likely
there filming for the Black Widow film
her hairs most likely red because she's
playing a young Natasha and why else
would the official Instagram page of
Marvel Studios be following her so for
those of you who have been wanting to
learn more about Natasha's past and
learned about Natasha as she was a kid
it looks like you're going to be getting
that chance and Black Widow so a lot of
great news happened just in the past few
days it looks like everything is getting
back on track and hopefully not too long
from now in a few months we're going to
get the first projects of phase 4 so let
me know what you are most excited about
for phase 4 in the comments down below
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
everything happening in the MCU for live
updates you can follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof